en directo a América edición nocturna es
momento de la información económica y
por ello me acompaña en el estudio mi
compañero Juan Pablo lucumí Juan Pablo
bienvenido hoy vamos a empezar esta este
repaso económico con temas que tienen
que ver con la guerra en Ucrania porque
entraron en vigor las que podrían ser
las sanciones más fuertes de la
comunidad internacional contra Rusia Así
es Valentina ya lo hablábamos en el
noticiero pues desde este lunes
empezaron a regir dos medidas la primera
es un boicot a las exportaciones de
petróleo por mar Aunque sí seguirá
llegando por oleoducto para blindar a
países como Hungría que no tiene salida
al mar y que depende en gran medida de
los hidrocarburos rusos la segunda y que
más ha molestado el kremlin es la de un
tope de 60 dólares por barril al precio
de su petróleo Bueno pero y esto
exactamente Cómo se traduce en la
relación comercial del bloque occidental
justamente con Moscú ya occidente no va
a comprar tanto petróleo pues al segundo
mayor productor mundial así que impacto
del tope se verá en las compañías de
seguros y otras empresas de la cadena de
suministro que sólo podrían tratar con
El crudo ruso si este tiene un precio
igual o inferior a ese tope por eso
muchos países estaban presionando para
que ese tope fuera más bajo por ejemplo
de 50 dólares ya que se estima que Rusia
le cuesta entre 30 y 40 dólares producir
un barril y su equilibrio fiscal se
lograría solo si vende a un precio de
entre 60 y 70 dólares lo que quiere
decir que con este límite de precios
todavía sigue siendo rentable para Rusia
o por lo menos no lo va a perder Pero
entonces por qué tomaron la decisión de
este tope Exactamente La Casa Blanca dio
explicaciones
Por qué 30 y no 60 y sé que ha habido
algunos comentarios por ahí entonces
mire el precio asegurará un descuento en
el petróleo ruso especialmente a la luz
de los 100 dólares por barril que
ganaron Sólo hace unos meses y se puede
ajustar con el tiempo para evitar que
Lucía se beneficia aún más de su Guerra
y así es creemos que es una acción sin
precedentes que estamos viendo en este
momento y demuestra la unidad que tienen
Estados Unidos y nuestros aliados y
socios y creo que esto es lo que creemos
que es un importante paso adelante
Juan Pablo pues sin duda es una medida
que ha generado diversas reacciones por
ejemplo que ha dicho la OPEP la
Organización de Países exportadores de
petróleo la OPEP y sus aliados incluida
Rusia hicieron lo que se esperaba en la
reunión del domingo pues manteniendo su
objetivo anterior de producción de crudo
que recordemos reduce en 2 millones la
producción mundial de barriles una
decisión que tomaron en Octubre y que
empezó a regir en noviembre la próxima
reunión programada del grupo es una
reunión del comité de seguimiento del
primero de febrero lo que significa que
salvo algunos acontecimientos
extraordinarios el objetivo de
producción actual se mantendrá estable
durante algunos meses bueno Y como como
se podría esperar este anuncio al precio
del petróleo ruso pues tuvo efecto en
los precios del petróleo en el mercado
mundial y miremos Cómo cerraron a nivel
general el brent de Reino Unido cayó un
2,99% dejando el precio del barril a 83
dólares en el último cierre de este
lunes pero durante la jornada reportó
caídas de Hasta el 3,4%, el doblete y de
Estados Unidos al cierre se recuperó Y
tuvo una muy leve ganancia y pues hasta
llegar hasta los 77 dólares el barril
Bueno ahora miremos Los indicadores
mundiales Pues porque seguro también se
vieron afectados por esta situación y
arrancamos con Wall Street porque las
acciones cerraron con profundas pérdidas
mientras los rendimientos del tesoro
subieron este lunes luego de varios
informes económicos que hablan de que la
dura lucha contra la inflación de la Fed
todavía continúa es decir no hay muchas
esperanzas de que bajen los tipos de
interés la bolsa en Europa siguió
también el comportamiento de Estados
Unidos pero cerrando en terreno mixto
con los anuncios del tope al pretorio
ruso muy latente y como suele ocurrir en
nuestra región seguimos la senda de
Estados Unidos y de Europa y todas
cerraron con profundas pérdidas Bueno
usted ya estaba hablando de América
Latina y ahora vamos a poner la lupa
sobre el comportamiento de la inflación
Cuáles son los datos más recientes
revisamos los datos inflacionarios del
mes de octubre que es el más reciente
que han liberado de forma oficial las
entidades pero pues hay que decir que
hay algunos también que Ya empezaron a
actualizar con el mes de noviembre si
nosotros revisamos los datos vemos que
por ejemplo solamente México Perú y
Brasil tienen datos de un solo dígito
Mientras que el resto tienen por encima
del 10% Y tenemos el caso particular de
Venezuela y Argentina que están por
encima del 80% en el caso de Venezuela
por ejemplo en el último mes registró
datos que pues van han empezado a subir
incluso con los meses anteriores como
Julio y agosto Aunque recordemos que en
enero estaba por mucho más encima al 300
o el 400 por ciento y pues este lunes el
gobierno colombiano también divulgó el
dato de inflación interanual de
noviembre el cual fue del
12,53% la más alta en tres años
exactamente desde marzo de 1999 no se
veía esta cifra el caso de Brasil es
exactamente opuesto porque desde agosto
el índice de precios al consumidor viene
reduciéndose mes a mes pasando del
11,89% que estaba en agosto al dato más
reciente que tenemos que fue en octubre
con un 6,47% pues Juan Pablo una región
de contrastes como ya usted nos lo ha
mostrado Muchas gracias por esta
ampliación económica lo invito a que se
quede con nosotros que ya continuamos
con directo a